خارطه هجمات السم الخفيف كما وصفت تتوسع
في ايران وكان التسمم بات معديا فمن
المدارس الى الجامعات ومن ثم مؤخرا محطات
القطارات اكثر من 120 مدرسه تعرضت فتياتها
للتسمم بالغاز او بالماده التي عجزت
السلطات الايرانيه حتى اللحظه من تحديد
ماهيتها المدارس التي تخطى عددها المئه
توزعت على اكثر من 25 محافظه بينها
كردستان وفارس وطهران ولورستان وصفهان
وكرمان بالاضافه الى عده جامعات ايضا
ومؤخرا ما زاد من خطوره الامر هي حالات
تسمم سجلت لفتيات ايرانيات داخل محطات
المترو والقطارات كما حدث مع العديد من
مستخدمات المترو بهارستان في اصفهان صباح
اليوم ايران انترناشونال اكدت اظهار مقاطع
فيديو لتدهور الحاله الصحيه لدى الفتيات
ولحجم الزحام في المستشفيات فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
النظام الايراني متمسك بروايه تعدد المواد
المستخدمه بالهجمات وبعضها مواد متاحه
يمكن ان تسبب تهيجا وفق وزاره الصحه حيث
قللت الوزاره طبعا من حجم واهميه ما يجري
لافته الى ان بعض الطالبات اللواتي تعرضن
للهجوم صبنا باعراض في الجهاز التنفسي
فيما عزت الحاله لدى فتيات اخرى الى
التاثر النفسي او الخوف الجماعي اي القلق
عند رؤيه جميع زميلاتهن تظهر عليهن
الاعراض فيعانين من نفس الاعراض دون سبب
بحسب ما نقلته ايضا ايران انترناشونال
وزعم هنا مسؤول بوزاره الصحه ان اقل من
10% من حالات التسمم كانت اعراضا حقيقيه
اما معظمها فيتعلق بالتوتر وهنا طبعا
مشاهدينا مئات الايرانيين وبمقدمتهم
اولياء الطالبات الذين يشاهدون سقوط
بناتهم الواحده ت اخرى منذ ثلاثه شهور
كثفوا احتجاجاتهم في الشارع حيث شهد
الطهران وشيراز والاهواز في وعده ايضا مدن
في كردستان ايران تجمعات احتجاجيه رغم
الاجواء الامنيه المشدده من قبل النظام
فيما قوات الامن هاجمت المحتاجين على
تسميم طالبات في مدينه مشهد شمال شرق
ايران واستخدم طبعا الغاز المسيل للطموح
[موسيقى]